the scariest chapter for me is the
medical chapter where our medical system
has been entirely captured by this woke
virus and so for example every year
there's like a conference where the best
doctors who deal with premature birth
babies get together and they talk about
it and they have like the four absolute
best to tell you what happened in the
last year because things are always
changing and improving in the field and
so they recently had this conference or
in about a year and a half ago maybe and
they realized that the Ford best doctors
in this field are white men and you
can't have that so now they're going to
introduce women and make sure that the
ethnicity spread is is wider on the
stage but so now you no longer have the
best actors you have good doctors maybe
but you're looking for other things
other than best and that is so scary and
then in order to get into medical
schools you need to write an essay on
how you're going to promote diversity
and and the rest in your practice and
it's terrifying it to me that really
takes away the ability of a doctor to
say what they want to say investigate
what they need to investigate and really
not feel like they are you know have to
conform to some ideas it's it's such a
good point because with a doctor you
don't want them thinking about any of
this nonsense you just want them to
treat you that's it right and yeah and
the gender thing comes up in the medical
thing too where the doctor has to
pretend that they don't know what gender
you are for real and you know they have
to give you tests that don't apply to
you because you know you say that you're
this gender and your your birth sex is
something different we also keep coming
across that and so it just every minute
that is spent on this people people are
going to die this is going to lead to
death we might not know it we might not
see it but it is going to happen and of
course because a woman having a heart
attack is very different to a male
having a heart attack absolutely and the
dosage that you have to give and all the
rest of it and there's I mean the heart
attack's a perfect example because
someone's having a heart attack you
don't have a lot of time to then go I
wonder what this person with a vagina
identifies as
that's exactly it and it's it that kind
of thing is really terrifying so my
co-author uh is the homeschooling mom of
six I have three kids I have two in
public one in private school and she
homeschools her children she pre-reads
the books she doesn't let them watch any
modern television or YouTube or anything
I'm much more permissive and for me we
kind of lay down the foundation at home
we we really talk about a lot of
different things that we wish we didn't
have to be talking about on a lot of
different levels but she'll say that no
matter how much she opts out of culture
she can't opt out of her pediatrician's
office and so this no matter how much
you want to pull your kids from this
Insanity you have to go to the doctor
sometimes and so you might not be
interested in woke you know but woke is
interested in you and how does this play
out against what I think is a very good
system again Dave and I talked about
this the federal system where you you
can do what you've done which is if you
don't like what's happening in the
jurisdiction that you live in you can
and move somewhere else like I are you
able in this country as an American to
go well I don't like this I am going to
move to wherever and there I can vote
for my school district or whatever to be
the way that I want is that still
possible or is this like you can't
escape it yes that is still possible in
some ways but the medical thing for
example that's a national accreditation
Society so it's not a local thing you
can't move to Florida you might you just
might find more doctors who don't
subscribe to this kind of thing and who
will do things you know in a normal way
even though they've been taught to do it
in an abnormal way you might find more
of them in places like Florida but they
have been accredited by the same
licensing groups that push this so it
and it's it's happening on such a wide
level that it's it's tough to find
rational sane doctors and you know even
in Florida we sort of have like a
whisper Network like is your doctor can
I have him like and that's the that's
how you find your md even here